hi everyone my name is sai venom and I'm
with the IBM cloud team today let's talk
about infrastructure is code
these days it's increasingly crucial to
automate your infrastructure as
applications can be deployed in
production up to hundreds of times per
day
in addition infrastructure is fleeting
and could be provisioned or deprovision
in response to load let's start with an
example let's say you're building out an
application and you've chosen a public
cloud now the first thing you've decided
to do is build your application on
kubernetes so we'll have a kubernetes
application stack now we don't actually
have to dive deeper into kubernetes
because it isolates the hardware from
the application layer so we don't
actually have to go in deeper
it'll manage that for us next let's say
that after a week of development we've
decided to bring in a VM that hosts a
legacy application that we haven't
modernized just yet so we'll bring on a
VM and now to actually connect up those
dots will need a PPC
so there we go we have a basic
infrastructure in place now let's say
that I've developed this it's great all
the infrastructure details are
documented now I'm ready to move it into
a test phase now I know that for best
practice what I should do is create a
whole new environment that mimics my dev
environment to do so I'll go back to my
documentation and start following the
steps to spin up that infrastructure but
let's say that maybe I forgot to
document one of the config switch is
that I've changed or maybe the platform
is different in how it handles
provisioning infrastructure regardless
the application and tests don't work the
same way in the new environment I decide
okay we need to fix this problem and to
never have this problem in the future
again we need to take advantage of
infrastructure as code let's talk about
the first approach to infrastructure
automation it's going to be imperative
now this is kind of intuitive for most
people because an imperative approach
allows you to define step by step how to
get your infrastructure into a certain
state so in general and imperative
approach would use something like a CLI
along with maybe a bash script so for
example in this in this case we could do
something like CLI create kubernetes and
then we would define some maybe
additional commands to customize that
kubernetes deployment will do the same
thing for the VM as well as the V PC so
an imperative approach has an advantage
it allows you to really define
step-by-step how your infrastructure is
provisioned and that generally comes
with more power as well because you're
using the cloud tools and and doing it
in a kind of step-by-step process but at
the same time this can come with
complexity for example if you wanted to
tear down your VMs or your environments
rather or let's say you wanted to scale
it up or down you would have to write
custom scripts
handled for you in an imperative
approach so this generally doesn't scale
well another approach to infrastructure
automation is going to be declarative
and this is actually my favorite
approach now a declarative approach
would be something like terraform and
what this basically allows you to do is
define the final state of your
infrastructure and then it lets the
provider handle the rest so instead of
defining every step you just define the
final state so in this example maybe you
would do something like define a
kubernetes resource and a VM resource as
well as a VP and our VPS VPC resource
and another great thing about this it's
generally managed through just simple
config Maps so if you wanted to do
something like define a host you could
do that maybe a domain or maybe even the
subnets so in general a declarative
approach allows you to more easily
manage the configuration and it's my
preferred approach for automating
infrastructure let's take this simple
example if you ran the imperative script
multiple times you would actually end up
with multiple environments and in
addition let's say one of the steps
halfway through failed you would have to
kind of add error handling to tear down
the steps that did succeed now with the
declarative approach no matter how many
times you run this script you end up
with the exact same infrastructure so
you could do it the first time provision
your environment and then maybe run it
again later on to ensure that your
environment hasn't changed so I'd say
this is very important to kind of
understand the different approaches to
infrastructure as code but in general I
do prefer a good declarative approach
next let's talk about DevOps now we all
understand how important I've ops is
when developing an application you'll
first write some code you'll want to you
know test that it actually works
and then you want to push it into
production and then you want to make
sure that all of that is kind of always
working and you can repeat those
processes now I know there's teams out
there that have a perfect agile devops
flow but because they're working with
legacy infrastructure they have to open
a ticket every time they want to get a
new VM and that's kind of just due to
the infrastructure that they're running
on now that really holds them back now
with infrastructure is code when it's
supported it allows you to treat your
infrastructure with the same level of
quality that you treat your code so this
includes things like versioning so
essentially you want to make sure that
anytime your infrastructure changes
you're tracking that and it's generally
a best approach for automation the last
thing I want to talk about is immutable
versus mutable infrastructure now
breaking that down an immutable
infrastructure is one that can't be
changed right it can't be mutated now at
first impression it might sound like a
bad thing but let's break this down by
seeing an example with a mutable
approach to infrastructure architecture
so we have our example here and let's
say that we're building out the app and
we decide we need a database so to do so
we'll run a script in our dev
environment this brings up that database
within our V PC now all of this is
working great so we say hey let's just
run that script across all of the
environments that we have now let's say
99% of the time that works fine but some
of the times it fails you're in a weird
limbo state so let's break that down so
we're going from version one to version
two now we have infrastructure code in
place to bring up version one but now we
ran this custom script to move it from
version one to version two what we've
essentially have right now is something
called configuration drift or
environment drift our our existing
environment is no law
matching what we have in our automation
now the problem is to kind of help debug
those problem situations you would kind
of have to wipe out the entire
environment and then redeploy version
one and then run those scripts now that
might seem okay the first couple times
to do it but when moving to scale it
becomes incredibly hard to maintain so
with an immutable approach to
infrastructure and infrastructure
automation every time you want to make a
change to the infrastructure you bring
up a brand new environment alongside the
old one and then once you verify that
they're both working you can bring down
the older version now it's a little
expensive because you got to imagine
that you're running both environments at
the same time but in general it's the
best practice to ensure that your
infrastructure can move to scale thanks
for joining me for this quick overview
of infrastructure as code if you want to
learn more about this or devops check
out the link below remember you can
always get started with a free account
on IBM cloud thank you